evening everyone and welcome to the next
revolution I'm Steve Hilton and this is
the home of positive populism pro-worker
pro-family pro community and especially
pro America a huge win for Bernie
Sanders in the Nevada caucuses last
night even President Trump tweeted this
congratulations Bernie and don't let
them take it away from you I think he's
enjoying this all right we'll get into a
lot of the moment along with Mike
Bloomberg humiliation in the debate last
week we've got a frightening preview of
the loonie left California policies that
may be coming to you and a more positive
preview of president Trump's trip to
India where he arrives in the next few
hours live with me in Los Angeles
tonight Kaylee McInerney Kira Davis
Sarah Carter and Henry Olson well it was
a blow out for Bernie in the Nevada
caucuses and he is now the Democrats
clear front-runner so it's time for a
closer look at Bernie and in particular
the superficial cliche trotted out by
nearly every pundit that Bernie is a
populist the Democrats version of Donald
Trump that is completely wrong and
tonight I'm going to show you why but
first I want to say this about Bernie I
do admire the way he's pushed himself to
the position he's in today through sheer
force of character and ideas I agree
with many of the things he says are
wrong with the country the corruption of
the establishment the way working people
lost power
I used to agree with him on immigration
until he totally changed his position
more on that in a moment and on a
personal note I've got a lot of time for
his campaign co-chair Nina Turner she's
a huge talent with a big future but here
comes the but no one should buy the
pundits lazy consensus that Bernie is a
populist like Trump he's not and here
are the four reasons why first Trump was
an outsider Bernie is actually an
insider before entering the presidential
race Donald Trump never ran for anything
he was never in politics before and
approached it like a problem solving
businessman he combined traditional
conservative ideas with new more
populist ones pro-business on tax and
regulation but pro-worker on trade and
immigration pro-america on defense
pro-family
on paid leave and child tax credits
conservative judges and criminal justice
reform
and perhaps in a long-term his most
significant policy shift of all uh
pending the establishment consensus on
China
Trump's original innovative policy mix
is something only an outsider could have
put together by contrast Bernie has been
a political insider all his life for
almost four decades he's collected
taxpayer-funded paychecks as a mayor a
congressman and now senator but he's not
even an effective insider he's
introduced 239 bills while in the Senate
guess how many became law too maybe for
once Hillary got it right when she said
nobody likes him nobody wants to work
with him he got nothing done here's the
second reason it's wrong to see Bernie
as just a trump of the left Donald
Trump's policies are mainstream Bernie's
are extreme the policy agenda President
Trump
ran on in 2016 has been implementing
since is based on mainstream positions
with majority support whether that's
strong borders renegotiating trade deals
cutting taxes or school choice but
Bernie's positions they are wildly out
of the mainstream they are extreme and
have only minority support open borders
rejected by over seventy five percent of
Americans abolishing ice rejected by
over fifty percent prisoners voting
rejected by nearly 70 percent abolishing
private health insurance rejected by a
majority and of course the multi
trillion-dollar green New Deal actually
the centerpiece of Bernie's plan for the
economy rejected by a massive 67% you're
not a populist if your policies aren't
popular here's the third big difference
between Bernie and Trump the president
stands up to the establishment in the
early days Trump had establishment
people all around him trying to block
him on everything trade China the war
endless wars immigration you name it but
the president stopped his populist
instincts and now we're seeing the
results that is a huge contrast with
Bernie in his last presidential campaign
he was firmly a
against open borders should we have a
completely open boiler so that anybody
can come into the United States of
America if that were to happen which I
strongly disagree with there is no
question in my mind that that would
substantially lower wages in this
country but he realized he couldn't get
anywhere with that position in the new
woke Democratic establishment so now
he's completely caved he's for
decriminalizing border crossings
breaking up ice the whole crazy package
but here's the fourth a most important
difference between Trump and Bernie and
the thing that the pundits most
infuriatingly get wrong they call them
both populist Bernie a populist of the
left Trump on the right
no populism means taking power out of
the hands of the elite and the
establishment and putting it in the
hands of the people
that's what Trump is doing deregulation
takes power from government bureaucrats
and puts it in the hands of employers
and business owners especially small
businesses who are hurting most by
over-regulation tax cuts put more
financial power in the hands of working
people judges like Gorsuch and Cavanaugh
and hundreds of others appointed by
Trump are upholding people's rights in
the Constitution and curbing the power
of the administrative state school
choice gives power to parents parental
leave gives power to families in so many
areas Trump is truly delivering the
populist promise of power to the people
Bernie wants to redistribute power all
right but he wants to take power from
the private-sector elite and give it to
a new public sector elite a new army of
bureaucrats and busybodies running
around telling you what to do once
Bernie's told them what to do
nationalized health care nationalized
rent control nationalized energy
wherever you look Bernie wants to
nationalize power populism is all about
decentralizing power bernie is the
direct opposite he is for centralizing
power he is not a populist he is a
socialist and by the way don't believe
the spin that socialism is nothing
unusual it's normal in places like the
UK or Sweden or Denmark that is rubbish
I know those countries what they have is
not Bernie's democratic socialism it is
social democracy and it is totally
different
nowhere in Europe is as Extreme as
Bernie's plan for America even the UK
with the National Health Service doesn't
ban private insurance Sweden has massive
school choice and vouchers Denmark has
one of the lowest levels of government
regulation in the world Bernie is a
Washington insider with extreme
socialist positions who panders to the
establishment when it suits his own
political purposes
I'll give the last word to a well known
Democrat who doesn't think that the
Democrats in the end will buy what
Bernie is selling they're not interested
in socialism in a revolution and are
like foolishness you here and in another
interview he went a little further than
foolishness most of the people aren't
into all this distracting bleep about
open borders and letting prisoners vote
Democrats talking about free college
tuition or debt forgiveness people all
over this country work their way through
school sent their kids to school paid
off student loans they don't want to
hear this bleep
you're so right James Carville people
don't want that bleep they don't want
socialism they want populism positive
populism and from President Trump that
is exactly what they're getting all
right let the pundits know what you
think of what they're saying about
Bernie please send this around stop them
getting it wrong follow us at Steve
Hilton X and that next Rev FNC we will
post this and we'd love you to share it